Bud Light to launch camouflage bottle
amid transgender controversy you know
Bud's now trying to go uh the other way
I just wonder how Wild it'll got Nathan
Bedford Forrest started an organization
called the Knights of the Church of the
Klu Klux Klan
and while that con that organization has
been controversial here in Heartland
we remember when your daddy went out and
he grabbed his hood the only thing he
took with him other than a torch can a
Bud Light
Heil Hitler Bud Light
some people think it was six million
but here at Bud Light we haven't seen
the numbers
we're simply saying that history is
never what any one person thinks
Bud Light
find your own number
foreign